hello and welcome everyone to today's
brilliant minds old questions virtual
talk our series spotlights high impact
research from across the academy from
computer science population and public
health to economics and today quantum
materials if you are not familiar with
us cfar is a global research
organization that convenes extraordinary
minds to address the most important
questions facing science and humanity
my name is fiona cunningham and i'm a
director of research at seapart and it
is my distinct pleasure to introduce you
to our two speakers today for today's
talk on superconductors are they the
next tech superstar
first we have pablo girillo herrera who
is a professor of physics at the
massachusetts institute of technology
pablo's group explores quantum transport
in novel condensed matter systems such
as graphene and topological insulators
his academic group advances fundamental
science in two-dimensional magnetism and
optics and opto-electronics of
low-dimensional materials
also joining us is atlanta halas who is
an assistant professor in the department
of physics and astronomy at the
university of british columbia research
in atlanta's group is focused on the
design and discovery of new quantum
materials using a broad range of crystal
growth techniques
her group is particularly interested in
establishing structure function
relationships in quantum materials to
facilitated the targeted design of
materials with novel or useful
properties
today's session will last approximately
30 minutes i will start the session with
a question before inviting our speakers
to ask one another questions for about
20 to 25 minutes
after this i will open it up to
questions from participants online
if you as an online audience member have
a question you can use the q a function
to submit it
we ask that you not use the chat
function to submit questions
lastly the session is being recorded and
will be available on the cfar website
next week
so
to get us started i'm going to throw out
the first question
and then leave it straight to atlanta
and pablo
what exactly is a superconductor and why
are they so important
terrific hi everybody and hi to fiona
thank you very much for this great
introduction i'm really excited to be
here today to talk about
superconductivity
so i think when trying to understand
what is a superconductor it really helps
first just to establish what is a normal
conductor so when we're thinking about
normal conductors these are metals that
are capable of
carrying an electric current so they can
carry electricity
um and so when we zoom in in a metal a
normal metal and we try to understand
how are they conducting electricity if
we zoomed into the level of individual
atoms and electrons what we would see
is a c as in a liquid of electrons that
are flowing through the material
carrying that electrical current
and in a normal conductor uh those
electrons are occasionally going to get
interrupted along their path they're
going to bounce into something or
collide and that's going to cause them
to lose their energy and impede the
forward flow of current
and because of this they transfer all
their energy back into
the atoms of the structure and for this
reason when we're working with
electronics things like our laptops
or our tvs if you leave them on for a
while you can actually begin to feel
them warm up that's because of those
collisions
and that's why it's also really
important for sensitive electronics to
have a fan to dissipate some of that
heat or else they can overheat and
that's really not good for the
performance of our electronics
so that's a normal conductor in a
superconductor those processes just
simply do not occur so a superconductor
can carry electrical current
for infinite time
without dissipating any of its
electrical current and transferring any
of its energy into the form of heat so
right away you can imagine that there
might be all sorts of applications that
can come from that zero resistance a
metal that can
carry electricity without losing any of
its energy
uh and so superconductors have a second
really important property which is known
as the meissner effect and this means
that they actually completely expel all
magnetic fields uh from inside of them
so
magnetic fields cannot penetrate a
superconductor and this is what
distinguishes it simply from a metal
that is just a very good conductor so we
could imagine a metal that was just
atomically perfect and it had none of
these scattering mechanisms but that's
not a superconductor a superconductor
also has to have this meissner effect
this expulsion of magnetic fields
and so
the actual physical mechanism that leads
to the superconducting state
is known as cooper pairing where
electrons which in a normal metal
they're just individual electrons one
electron is one electron but in a
superconductor every electron finds a
partner and forms a cooper pair
and this is a truly quantum mechanical
uh process
and it's through this pairing that
superconductors achieve these properties
of zero resistance and the meissner
effect
so i would like to ask pablo if you
could tell us a little bit about
where are superconductors uh being used
in the world today like are there
superconductors around me uh do i
interact with them on a day-to-day basis
thank you very much alana and again it's
a pleasure to be here with all of you
so indeed um we have superconductors in
many places nowadays and
it's a technology that it's really
fundamental for
our you know current society and
we you know plenty of us are hoping that
they will be a technology that will
become even more prevalent so
perhaps one of the examples where most
people might be familiar with
superconductors is in magnetic resonance
imaging systems
those systems have you know a big coil
okay and that coil turns out to be made
with a superconducting material okay and
what happens is for magnetic resonance
imaging you need a very high magnetic
field and those high magnetic fields you
generate them by running a current
through a conductor but if it's a
regular conductor because they dissipate
a lot of energy it's very costly and
also very difficult to generate such
high magnetic fields however
in superconductors because the
electrical currents and superconductors
do not
dissipate any energy you can easily you
know establish very high currents in
these coils and you can generate very
large magnetic fields so pretty much all
magnetic resonance imaging systems in
the world in all of the hospitals in the
world actually used superconductors and
that's you know sort of one
widespread application of
superconductors
we have also superconductors in other
technologies for example
probably plenty of you have heard about
levitating trains okay the mac left that
you know there's some in japan and in
china so these
they make use of the fact that when you
run currents through this again through
the superconductors they they spell you
know
they generate the magnetic field and
that also if conversely if you have
magnetic field somewhere it cannot
penetrate the superconductor and that is
to repulsion okay between objects so
the way a magnetic you know levitated
train works is because you have these
superconductors and you have magnetic
fields and they are repelling the
magnetic field that creates a repulsive
force that you know levitates the trains
and because there is no contact between
the train and the you know the rail
tracks you know then you have very
little dissipation and that allows
actually the trains to go very very fast
okay so the superconducting limited
trains are the fastest strains that we
have in the world so that's those are
just two examples maybe we'll we'll talk
a little bit a little bit more about
something that some of you may have
heard about which is that nowadays
for quantum computers one of the
technologies that is most used uh
consists actually of using
superconductors also for quantum
computation and that's something which
is very interesting but maybe we'll
touch a little bit uh
about that later now you may wonder why
don't we use more superconductors in
many other things and that's because
it is actually in
superconductors that
we're aware of most of them actually
work only at relatively low temperatures
yeah so right now
these these superconducting technologies
are technologies where it is it pays off
to cool down the system to low
temperatures so that the systems can
become superconductor and then you can
make use of the superconducting
properties okay
if we could use you know if we had
superconductors that worked at let's say
room temperature for example then we
would be able to make you know to apply
them to plenty plenty of technologies
for example regular transmission of
electricity in lines without dissipation
and
you know mri systems are trained that
don't need
cool down plenty plenty of other
applications would be possible if we had
superconductors at room temperature
however
um
we do not have currently superconductors
that work at room temperature that can
be used in applications okay there are
only special cases which
we might mention later about this so
basically
you know part of what you know lana and
myself and plenty of other scientists
are trying to do is to see if we can
find in new superconductors that you
know
would be both for fundamental you know
interest and as well as applications
so so i wanna you know throw back a
question at alana so how do you find a
new superconductor
yeah thanks um so actually my my
research area is in crystal growth and
materials discovery so what you see
behind me is part of my crystal growth
lab where we're
trying to make materials that don't
already exist in nature and understand
their properties including looking for
materials that might
be relevant to superconducting
technologies
so right now our approach to looking for
superconductors is unfortunately a bit
of trial and error the problem is that
we don't understand completely all of
the ingredients that lead to
superconductivity
actually we can kind of think of two
classes of superconductors we can think
of conventional superconductors and
unconventional superconductors and the
conventional ones we tend to understand
quite well
but the problem is that they have very
low superconducting temperatures so this
uh
idea of a transition temperature between
a normal state and a superconducting
state is something that characterizes a
superconductor and we would like that
temperature to be as high as possible in
order to
be able to use it in um in real world
applications
so that we don't have to cool down using
say liquid nitrogen or material to make
it superconduct so these conventional
superconductors they're generally not
good for this they superconduct at
temperatures
well below minus 200 degrees celsius
very low temperatures
but they're a second class of
superconductors called unconventional
superconductors and these are the ones
that are more technologically uh
relevant because they have temperatures
that are are approaching um or
surpassing the boiling point of liquid
nitrogen so we can cool them in
hospitals to use them as
the magnets inside of mris
but widespread applications would
require them to reach you know much
closer to room temperature
and for that we don't have great ways of
predicting which materials
could form these superconducting states
and so when it comes to materials
discovery
we just have to make
a lot of attempts and see what happens
and hope for some serendipitous
discovery so we really would like to
better understand the ingredients for
superconductivity so that we could
design new superconductors that can be
used in technologies
so actually speaking of discovering
superconductors pavlo you recently
made big headlines for your discovery of
a new superconductor in a material that
normally doesn't superconduct i wonder
if you could explain a little bit uh
what the significance of that discovery
was
yes indeed so
we you know speaking of serendipity you
know this is something that you know it
was a nice surprise that happened in my
lab a few years ago
so we were investigating the electronic
properties of a material called graphene
graphene is a one atom thick
material it's a sheet of carbon one atom
thick so it's the thinnest material that
exists in the world it turns out to be a
very good conductor but not a
superconductor okay
now
because we can you know isolate a single
sheath
we can also isolate two of them and we
can stack them on top of each other okay
so that's something that we try to do
and in particular one thing that um it
was not possible to do in the history of
material science until very recently was
to stack two materials on top of each
other and control the relative angle
between the two crystalline lattices of
these two materials okay so it turns out
now we can do these things we can put
one material one atom thick on top of
another material one atom's thick
and twist them with respect to each
other it seems sometimes people call
these twistronics okay for twistable
electronics and
we were playing with this thing with oh
let's just twist on top of each other
and let's see what happens it turns out
the electronic mechanical optical
properties
of the two twisted sheets are completely
different you know they can dramatically
change as a function of the twist angle
of this angle of rotation
and then there were some theoretical
predictions from from some colleagues
who said that if we rotate these two
sheets by a very specific angle
1.1 degrees okay which is called the
magic angle
then the system would behave in a very
unusual way
they didn't tell us exactly what would
happen but they said it would behave in
a very unusual way you know
basically what they say that the
velocity of the electrons would slow
down a lot okay and the electrons would
be moving very slowly in this lattice so
we wanted to investigate this and we
made such devices and we cool down to
low temperatures and to our very
surprise we discovered that these very
slow moving electrons suddenly could
turn the system into a superconductor
so it's a superconductor which is
made out of non-superconducting
materials it's all made in carbon most
superconductors have very exotic
elements you know embedded in in in as
part of their chemistry but this is just
made in simple carbon so this came
indeed as a big surprise
and not only it it you know it came as a
big surprise what happens also is that
this material has
very few electrons a very small density
of electrons and it super conducts at a
relatively high
electron temperature so its behavior
seems very similar to many of the
unconventional superconductors that that
that a lot of you were mentioning before
so
in connection with with with this you
know this theme that you mentioned that
what you know we're trying to understand
what are the key ingredients or these
very unusual or unconventional
superconductors
so what people you know
you know part of the community in in
graffiti in this new system is trying to
think okay if we could make
superconductivity twisting these two
graphene sheets out of
non-superconductors
and it happens to be such a strong
superconductor maybe there is some
fundamental key ingredient
there in that system that we could
understand and perhaps you know if we
understand it properly we could try to
extrapolate this or use that knowledge
to to find out uh other superconductors
so so i want to throw back at you alana
so let's imagine that we figure out how
superconductors work
so can we use
basic
physics principles to engineer new
superconductors what are the key element
issues that we need to figure out
yeah
so
as soon as we were in a position where
we thought we understood exactly what
were the essential ingredients
to having higher temperature
superconductors
then it becomes a materials design
problem uh and that's where
people like me who discover materials
can potentially have a really big impact
so our process uh in designing materials
is a little bit like constructing a
recipe like a cooking recipe from
scratch
because we have basically a pantry of
ingredients and those ingredients are
the periodic table so
there's roughly 70 elements that we can
choose to work with
and then we're gonna mix and match them
in different ways uh and try to elicit
the types of properties we would like
them to have
yes and pablo's showing uh his periodic
table coffee mug
he's putting me to shame as the
materials person
um so uh once we're putting them
together it's actually really it has to
do with how we put them together that
matters um and here we're thinking about
how the atoms are actually arranged at
the scale of individual atoms so the
material that pablo was describing
graphene
it's very famous for having a honeycomb
network of carbon atoms so the carbon
atoms look exactly like what you would
see in a beehive these hexagonal shapes
arranged on an edge-sharing
array
and so that's one type of what we call a
crystal lattice one way that atoms can
be arranged but there are many others
and we know that the interesting
properties that materials have their
electronic properties like
superconductivity are always a
consequence of the arrangement of the
atoms how the atoms are are
arranged into a lattice and so
if we knew which chemical elements
should be favorable and we knew which
arrangement of chemical elements should
be favorable
then we have a few of our key
ingredients in order to start to
construct a recipe to look for these
materials and we could do it in a far
more
targeted way than what we're doing
currently
currently since we don't know exactly
what we're looking for
we're using sort of um
kind of approximations we're looking at
materials that already superconduct and
we're looking for things that are
similar but there could be something
completely different that's out there
that's not yet been discovered that we
just don't even know to look for
because we don't understand what about
it would give rise to superconductivity
so that's the kind of information that
we're missing right now
so you've heard us say in the course of
this conversation the word quantum a few
times
and so i would like to ask pablo
to maybe tell us a little bit about
other classes of quantum materials and
their technological promise because
superconductors are just one class of
materials that we generally refer to as
quantum materials and i'd like to hear a
bit about that
that's right
so in general we refer to quantum
materials uh
for materials where quantum mechanics
you know the theory of physics that you
know we believe explains you know pretty
much all the behavior of you know
materials in nature
is is important and plays a key role in
some of the very exotic manifestations
of of these materials you know and one
of them is superconductors which is very
spectacular this is you know zero energy
dissipation and this mice and effect
that exposed magnetic field but there
are plenty of other materials that have
very unique properties that could be
used for
for technology if we you know if we
could harness you know the full
potential
so some of them
are you know you have heard plenty of
you have heard about them for example
fero magnets okay or ferroelectric
materials these are materials where
quantum mechanics plays an important
role in their properties
we have more exotic types for example
quantum spin liquids
or topological materials okay it's a
material that maybe not a lot of you
have heard about but where the electrons
have very special properties very unique
behaviors which are
difficult to understand if you consider
electrons one by one independently we
say that there is a collective behavior
of these electrons
that leads to we often refer to this
emergence emergent behavior okay that is
collective that you cannot understand
just by looking at the individual
electrons but that you need to consider
the whole collective of electrons in
order to see this very special
manifestation and this very special
properties for example let me point out
so
is a topic of research which is very you
know which people like a lot and in the
past decade a lot of people have been
investigating are topological materials
these topological materials can have
also conduction without dissipation at
the edges of the material at the
surfaces or at the edges in a
two-dimensional version now
does that make them superconductors no
they're not superconductors because they
do not expel the magnetic field they
don't have that monster effect but in
terms of potential applications of
having materials that do not dissipate
energy those could also be useful
in particular in some
nanoelectronics you know applications so
these are just some of the things that
um
we you know some of the behaviors you
know collective behaviors of electrons
in materials that that we can explore in
opponents liquids topological materials
superconductors termites and
ferroelectrics and plenty others okay
and this is you know i i hope that you
you will be curious about this and you
start googling about quantum materials
and see what is out there and you know
perhaps you know one last question that
that you know because it has received a
lot of attention recently i want to ask
alana so
what is the highest known temperature of
superconductors that we know about
and
what about superconductors that conduct
much higher temperatures
yeah so this has definitely been
something that we've all been seeing in
the news recently which is reports of
superconductivity approaching very close
to room temperature but there's one
really important caveat of this
discovery which is that it's in
materials that are actually gases uh
under normal conditions and they're only
turned into solids that superconduct
under extremely high pressures like
giggle pascals of pressure so this is
thousands and thousands and thousands of
times the pressure that you experience
just
in air so atmospheric pressure like you
can think of the pressures at the
deepest point of the ocean and then
thousands of times more pressure than
that
um so these materials do have remarkable
properties
including superconducting very close to
room temperature but it is not very
likely to find widespread use in
applications because of this requirement
of needing
really high pressure conditions which
requires um a very complicated
experimental apparatus something that's
large and sort of cumbersome to use so
it's not going to be usable say in the
context of these magnetic levitation
trains or mris
but it's still a really important
discovery because it tells us that there
is no limitation on super conductivity
reaching 300 kelvin which is room
temperature
um so for a long time physicists have
wondered is there some inherent
limitation to how how high a material
could superconduct is it even feasible
that a material could superconduct at
room temperature
and this answers the question that yeah
there's no seeming reason that a
material can't superconduct at room
temperature it's just a matter of
finding that right material that can do
it without those extreme pressures
applied
thank you uh that was
excellent and i think it's fair to say
that most of the audience at home could
actually follow along with what you were
doing with everything physics there and
we really appreciate it
so we we do have some questions from the
audience and i'm i'm happy to share
those questions with you and they're
actually around artificial intelligence
so this is a question from um
from a viewer named mark so so given the
complexity in the search for
superconductors material composition mix
alignment
is there any an analytical process to
predict superconduction can you use
machine learning to facilitate rapid
rapid iterative trial and error
processes in the search for new
superconductors
this is a really fantastic uh question
it's a little bit beyond uh my expertise
but
uh i can comment a little bit about the
use of machine learning and materials
discovery
so
uh
yes this this is a an area of active
interest right now i i don't know that
it's been super successfully applied to
predicting new superconductors uh but it
is being used to predict new materials
because
one thing we often don't know is just
when we combine two elements will it
form a new material or is it sort of
going to want to stay separate like will
those elements want to react with each
other and form something new
and so that also often requires just a
trial and error approach but machine
learning techniques have proven quite
successful at predicting the stability
of new phases um so there are sorts of
predictive capabilities that can be used
to um predict new phases it's just that
when we get to the level of electrons
that's where things get so much more
complicated and so um
there's just a higher level of
complexity but i don't think it's
outside the realm of possibility
indeed there are we we have a
current theory of superconductors
conventional superconductors
so there you have actually analytical
formulas for what ingredients would be
important you know what would you want
to have in a superconductoric material
in order for it to become a
superconductor okay and in that sense
uh some of these
room temperature high pressure
superconductors that alana mentioned a
little bit ago those people have
indications from theory that they might
be high temperature superconductors
because they knew that they had an
important ingredient and
it's called electron phonon coupling and
density of states things which are a bit
too complex to explain now but people
synthesize those materials and and put
them under high pressures because they
suspect that they might become
superconductors at very high
temperatures now that work for those
materials that
you know
you have to apply high pressures for the
unconventional superconductors those
that have relatively high critical
temperatures at atmospheric pressures
and that that they might be more useful
for for applications
for those we do not have a theory
nowadays that is commonly agreed upon in
a community that would allow us to
to search uh for for new superconductors
and as a result
most of the unconventional
superconductors have been discovered by
chance you know by accident you know or
with a little bit of intuition but not
real theory guiding them you know this
happened with the high temperature
cuprate superconductors it happened with
the iron nipped superconductors it
happened with many other unconventional
superconductors it was sort of people
you know with some intuition with a good
you know sense of smell going in some
direction but not really you know
thinking you know with a clear
theoretical prediction that they would
turn out to be super demand force i like
that the small analogy that's a good one
so i have a 30 second question
um so
imagine a hundred years from now how do
you see superconductors changing our
world
elena you want to go first you go ahead
so um
i think that you know let's assume that
in 100 years you know it has taken
it is taking more than 40 years to
you know to understand
unconventional superconductivity let's
be optimistic and let's say that in 100
years we have understood it and we've
enabled them to synthesize new
superconductors i think that that would
truly lead to a revolution in technology
because we would be able to do amazing
things for example
all those you know quantum computers
that use superconducting technology
nowadays that are only a very low
temperature we might perhaps be able to
use them at room temperature we would be
able to this you know transport energy
in cables in wires and you know home in
cars it's high power transmission all
using superconductive wires that would
not dissipate ng we will have no limits
for the applications of large magnets
and magnetic fields generated by
superconductors in a variety of
applications so this is something that
would completely change our technology
the way you know the way we know it
nowadays computing everything
great yeah i'll just add that um
you know beyond just all of those
fantastic applications of
superconductivity i think one thing
that's potentially really exciting is
that by studying superconductors it's
giving us this very sophisticated
understanding of the quantum
interactions in matter which could lead
to other types of phenomena that we
don't even know about today so
superconductivity itself was completely
discovered by chance
and i think it's really exciting that
there are other chance discoveries
out there waiting for us to discover and
superconductors are sort of a pathway to
making those discoveries
i think that was the perfect way to
close it off and so unfortunately that's
all the time that we have for today so
thank you to all who are joining us from
home and a huge thank you to pablo
drilla herrera and atlanta halas for
sharing their insights with us
please visit our website cfar.ca to find
out more about this series and view a
recording of this talk which should be
posted early next week
thank you
thank you everyone bye thank you
[Music]
you